[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - THE OTHER JOSH COHEN,
"NEIL LIFE"]
MARK DOUGLAS: What's up, Google?
Who's ready to rock?
All right, that's a Google rock.
Come on.
I want to actual rock.
Guys, I saw this show yesterday,
"The Other Josh Cohen."
It is amazing.
Some of the most
talented performers
I've ever seen in my life
are about to come up here
and they've given up part of
their Valentine's Day for you.
This is a closed laptop meeting.
I used to work here.
I know the-- I know the terms.
No ping is going to be more
exciting than what these people
are about to bring to you.
So ladies and gentlemen,
without further ado,
please give it up for the cast
of "The Other Josh Cohen."
I'm trying to do an Oprah.
Cohen.
Take it away, Josh Cohens.
JANE BRUCE: And I'm ready.
STEVE ROSEN: 1, 2, 3, 4.
DAVID ROSSMER: Hi.
Hello.
Good afternoon.
I am so glad you're here.
I really appreciate you coming.
Straight from the west side
theater in midtown Manhattan,
if the shirts haven't
told you already,
we are the cast of the rock and
roll romantic musical comedy,
"The Other Josh Cohen."
Thank you for joining us.
We're so happy to have
you with us today.
One guy said he had
to come because he
loves getting out of meetings.
That is a true story.
It is not the story we're
telling today, but it's true.
The story we are telling
today is also true.
It actually happened last
year on Valentine's Day
to a poor schlub
named Josh Cohen.
Hi, I'm Josh Cohen.
STEVE ROSEN: Hi, I'm Josh Cohen.
DAVID ROSSMER: One year
ago, I looked like that.
That's me.
Oh, mustache, what
was I thinking?
STEVE ROSEN: Hey.
[ARTISTS SINGING "ONLY THE
BEGINNING"]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID ROSSMER: Thank you.
Now, a lot will happen before
Josh's day actually comes.
And-- and before this next
song, when this next song
takes place, it
has been three days
since I have been robbed of
literally everything but a Neil
Diamond CD that we stole from
the back of our mother's car.
And at this point
in the story, it
is a time to go back to work.
STEVE ROSEN: And oddly enough,
it felt like Neil came with me.
I had listened to him
for 72 straight hours,
and it made the journey
from overwrought and corny
to comforting and awesome.
Every aspect of my mundane daily
life started to sound like him.
[ARTISTS SINGING "NEIL LIFE"]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID ROSSMER: And
last but not least, we
take ourselves in our story
after some twists and turns
to February 14.
V-Day has arrived.
And, well, I come home to
three letters in my mailbox.
The first is a Valentine's
Day card from my mother.
STEVE ROSEN: Aw.
DAVID ROSSMER: The
second is a bill.
STEVE ROSEN: Great.
DAVID ROSSMER: But
the third letter
is a sketchy little envelope
with no return address.
And inside is a
check from some lady
named Irma Cohen for $56,000.
STEVE ROSEN: Wait a second.
DAVID ROSSMER: And for the
first time in my existence,
I get excited to think
about my extended family--
STEVE ROSEN: Of course.
DAVID ROSSMER: --who
no one knows more about
than Aunt B. She knows
everything about everyone,
whose noses were
deviated septums
and which were sweet 16s.
Which is good.
Because I have about
6 billion cousins.
CATHRYN WAKE: Hi, Carol.
DAVID ROSSMER: Kind of cousins.
CATHRYN WAKE: Hey, Angelo.
DAVID ROSSMER:
Hearing-impaired step-uncles.
CATHRYN WAKE: Scott, welcome.
DAVID ROSSMER: And they
all step back to one very
virile man, my great
grandfather, Samuel Cohen.
[ARTISTS SINGING "SAMUEL COHEN'S
FAMILY TREE"]
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE ROSEN: Thank you.
MARK DOUGLAS: Give it up for the
cast of "The Other Josh Cohen."
[APPLAUSE]
Ba, ba, ba, ba, ba.
We're going to do a
quick reset of the stage.
I'm going to ask
them some questions.
And there's a
microphone over there.
If any audience members
want to ask questions,
you can go ahead,
line up whenever,
and I will let you
ask them a question.
How's everybody doing?
First thing I want to do is
have you go down the line,
introduce yourself, and say
which part you play, or parts,
because some of
you play about 85.
So--
DAVID ROSSMER: My
name is David Rossmer.
I play narrator Josh Cohen
because Steve and I both play
the same part, one year apart.
And the story basically
unfolds with me
telling the story of what
happened to me one year ago.
And he's living in
it as I'm telling it.
So I sort of have the-- the
opportunity to kind of know
that things will be OK,
there's a happy ending coming,
but he does not.
So that's my part, that's
sort of a narrator character.
STEVE ROSEN: I'm
Steve Rosen, and I
play the guy that doesn't
know any of the things
that he just talked about.
I play Josh Cohen
one year ago, when
he was about 15
pounds heavier and had
a really awesome mustache.
I'm Jane Bruce.
I play a bunch of people.
I play Neil Diamond, and I
play 80-something-year-old Irma
Cohen, and I play really,
really super randy Samuel Cohen.
I play Josh's sister
and Josh's mother.
It's so great.
MARK DOUGLAS: I just wanted
to do a quick correction.
You actually play
a lot of people.
That's what it says
in the playbill.
JANE BRUCE: Oh, yeah.
That's true.
That's my actual--
MARK DOUGLAS: You
play a lot of people.
JANE BRUCE: --character
description.
MARK DOUGLAS: Just kidding.
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE: Hi,
I'm Elizabeth Nestlerode.
I play a couple of characters.
I believe technically I am--
I am at least one other person.
MARK DOUGLAS: At least
one more person, yeah,
that's what it says.
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE: And
I play 11 instruments.
CATHRYN WAKE: My
name's Cathryn Wake.
My title is a bunch
of other people.
I play characters like
you just saw, Aunt B,
I play a porn star
named Cherry Lips who
is the star of "Oversexed
Injury Lawyers."
MARK DOUGLAS: Now, why didn't
you do that song today?
CATHRYN WAKE: I-- gosh darnit.
You have to see the show.
MARK DOUGLAS: Exactly.
CATHRYN WAKE: You'll
have to see the show.
MARK DOUGLAS: There's a
lot more you're missing.
CATHRYN WAKE: And about
eight other characters.
LOUIS TUCCI: Hi,
I'm Louis Tucci.
I play, actually, Josh's
dad, who is a dentist.
And he checks his
messages every 30 minutes.
I also play Mr. [INAUDIBLE],,
who is the superintendent,
and I also play his boss,
Bill, amongst other people.
LUKE DARNELL: Hi,
I'm Luke Darnell.
I-- I am the rest of the people.
It amounts to, I think,
seven or eight characters,
including Josh's brother-in-law,
and his strange neighbor,
and a friend of the family,
and one particularly secret
character we can't
divulge just now.
Or can we?
DAVID ROSSMER: I think we can.
LUKE DARNELL: I'm
freaking Darth Vader.
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE: Yeah.
CATHRYN WAKE: He's Darth Vader.
LUKE DARNELL: Yeah, with
one of the coolest entrances
in musical theater history.
But that I won't tell.
You have to come and see it.
Oh, and I play, I think,
five instruments in the show.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
I mean, this was,
like, the radio play
version of what you'll see.
I mean, there's so
much movement in this.
Like, if I didn't
speak English, if I
didn't know what the
hell you were saying,
I would enjoy just the
aspect of you guys just
running all over the place.
And I don't even know--
is it hard to maintain
the 15 pounds with all the
running around
that you're doing?
Because I feel like you would--
I mean, I'm serious.
It's like a workout.
I would have to do
so much work just
to stand in the right place that
you guys are standing on stage,
much less sing once I got there.
STEVE ROSEN: One of my greatest
skills is putting on weight.
So thank you for that.
But it's a natural talent.
It was god-given.
You should meet my family.
We've all been graced with it.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, no, I--
not to name drop a little bit,
my friend Steve Boyer, who was
in the show "Hand to God"--
DAVID ROSSMER: I know him well.
MARK DOUGLAS: He--
I went to visit him after
a show and he was, like,
chugging Ensure or
protein shakes because he
couldn't-- because he was just
sweating so much every night.
And--
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: --but
so, it's really--
very talented.
STEVE ROSEN: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
MARK DOUGLAS: This
might have-- this
might have been because I
was too close to the stage,
but I don't know if this
was a detail that I should
or shouldn't notice,
because I felt
like Josh changed
a lot in a year,
but his fashion sense
didn't change too much.
And previous Josh
had on New Balance,
and then present
Josh had on Skechers.
I feel like that's at
least a lateral move.
But maybe I was just too close.
DAVID ROSSMER: Those
are the little Easter
eggs you get when you sit in
the front, that and our spit.
It's really, it's--
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, I did--
DAVID ROSSMER: There's a
lot of perks to sitting
in the first few rows.
MARK DOUGLAS: I got
to see the spit,
but I was kind of
off to the side.
So it was nice to just
see the poor victims.
DAVID ROSSMER: It's like Shamu.
It's like the first
few rows may get wet.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, I'm a--
I'm a sucker for any kind of
immersive, interactive stuff,
where the audience comes out
at you, spits on you, whatever.
I just, like, oh, my god.
He's over there.
Now he's over there.
And how did he get a bass?
Are there any
people that are not
as enthusiastic and
receptive to that,
like when you interact with them
and they were just like, no.
Or any good stories about that.
STEVE ROSEN: Yeah, go ahead.
JANE BRUCE: Oh, there's-- in
Samuel Cohen which you just
saw, there's a moment where I
try and find basically as many
women in the audience as
I can to flirt with me.
And there have been a couple of
shows where I go over to a lady
and she does not want it.
And it's really--
that's a bummer.
But I keep trying.
MARK DOUGLAS: She's insane,
whoever that woman is.
JANE BRUCE: I just find another.
It's great.
MARK DOUGLAS: There you go.
And you are-- you and
Cathryn are both pretty new
to the show--
JANE BRUCE: Indeed.
MARK DOUGLAS: --which was a
shock because I felt like,
watching it, the choreography,
just being in the right place
at the right time,
I saw somebody
throw a prop in the
refrigerator at one point
and then get it later.
I just felt like, OK,
this is a company that's
just been doing this for years.
And I would have never known
that you guys just started.
What was the learning process
for both of you like for this?
JANE BRUCE: Well, to start, it
helped that we're, like, really
talented, you know?
MARK DOUGLAS: Right.
Sure, sure.
That you're a Jedi, OK.
STEVE ROSEN: And modest.
JANE BRUCE: I'm--
I'm joking.
It was really daunting.
It's definitely hard work and
learned mostly by watching.
I watched the show,
like, 14 or 15 times,
and had a couple rehearsals,
and fortunately, everyone's
really, really, really
nice, except for Steve.
And-- and--
MARK DOUGLAS: And you get
to play Neil Diamond, which
is the best.
JANE BRUCE: I know.
It's really fun.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's--
I actually wanted--
like, I always play a
game when I watch a show
and when I pretend I'm as
talented as the people on stage
where I go, what's my part?
What's my part?
And I was like,
OK, Luke, oh, yeah.
That guitar solo
is too hard for me.
Yeah.
And-- and actually, your part,
I was like, I want that one.
Which is--
JANE BRUCE: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: --which
is nice, you know?
That the woman part is
the one that I want.
That it's that well--
you know, it's not
just a white guy just
talking about himself, right?
I don't know.
Let me just go
back to these here.
Sorry, any questions
from the audience?
JANE BRUCE: It's a blast though.
And I know Cathryn
had a lot because she
had to take over the drums.
I mean--
MARK DOUGLAS: I know.
JANE BRUCE: --that's
an enormous job.
MARK DOUGLAS: And had you
played the drums before?
CATHRYN WAKE: I had a kit in
my basement when I was 12,
but no, I took over for
Hannah Ellis who is just
this incredible lady
drummer, and definitely
had her blessing.
But I played drums incessantly.
And apologized to all of
my neighbors and roommates,
but I didn't stop playing
drums for two weeks.
MARK DOUGLAS: Was that--
was that the main sort
of challenge, or--
CATHRYN WAKE: That
was definitely,
like, a hurdle to get
over, but again, this
is the most welcoming,
incredible family to fall into.
Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: One thing I
have to say that I really
noticed about when
you played Aunt B was
how much-- it was like an
acting lesson of don't act old.
If it was like-- act--
old people act young, they just
can't quite do the movements.
I was just-- I was kind
of blown away about just--
CATHRYN WAKE: I think
she's got some moves.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
CATHRYN WAKE: I really do.
I think she's nimble.
MARK DOUGLAS: What's the-- is
there a dance move that kind
of gets you into that, or--
CATHRYN WAKE: Oh, god.
You know, I don't call
myself a dancer at all--
MARK DOUGLAS: I feel like
it's a shoulder thing.
CATHRYN WAKE: --but
there's a lot of shoulders
and there's a lot of hips.
MARK DOUGLAS: Sassy shoulders.
CATHRYN WAKE: And whatever
else happens, all bets
are off, honestly.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
Who is probably the
busiest in the show?
Is there-- is
everybody equally busy?
Everybody,
CATHRYN WAKE: Everybody.
STEVE ROSEN: I think we're
all busy in different ways.
I mean, I-- I don't play
a lot of instruments
but I handle a lot of props.
So papers, and pens, and
things, are my instruments,
but I think that between
everybody on stage,
I think we play 53 characters,
and I want to say--
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
STEVE ROSEN: --something like
more than two dozen instruments
over the course of 90 minutes.
So we're all pretty busy.
It's like a thrill ride.
Once you get on, it's
just you're on the ride
and you get out of its way.
It's going to keep going.
It's really fun to do.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's awesome.
So now when you bring new
people into the show, I noticed,
like-- so are the tracks
kind of set in stone?
Would you ever bring
somebody in who's
like, look, the drums
just aren't happening.
So can we do a--
you know, I-- no?
DAVID ROSSMER: I think
the show would sound worse
without drums, but
we could try it.
MARK DOUGLAS: No, I'm
saying could you move,
could you change the tracks?
DAVID ROSSMER: Like a beatboxer.
Maybe if someone was like,
but I beatbox really well.
MARK DOUGLAS: Could you be
like, hey, for this one,
can I play the bass instead?
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah, yeah.
Well, it's-- no.
We would never do that.
That would be crazy.
But what we-- what
we have done is
while we were in rehearsal,
right up to literally
our previews, people
were changing instruments
because this cast is
so incredibly talented.
The director, Hunter
Foster, the day--
I think the day of our
first preview was like,
you know, I think
this scene would
work better if
Louis played guitar
and Luke played the bass.
And we were like, that's crazy.
You can't make them switch
instruments right on the spot.
And 10 minutes later, they
had switched instruments
and were playing totally new
parts, and new instruments,
and new blocking,
and everything,
and we were like, OK, I
guess they can do anything.
And that is really-- this
company can do anything.
They will pick--
they're like, oh, I
don't know how to
play this harmonica.
Badoo, badoo, doo, doo.
It's unbelievable.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, I think
Louis had the best bass
face, though.
LOUIS TUCCI: Thank you.
MARK DOUGLAS: I don't know if--
MARK DOUGLAS: --if that's
something you work on.
LUKE DARNELL: Can you give
us the bass face, Louis?
LOUIS TUCCI: Bass face.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, at one
point you came during the show--
LOUIS TUCCI: It's on
the poster, isn't there?
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
LOUIS TUCCI: Yeah,
the bass face.
MARK DOUGLAS: At one point,
you were, like, right up close
to me, just--
and I get nervous when there's--
make eye contact with a
performer, so I kind of just
was--
but in my head, just
know that I was like--
just Neil--
LOUIS TUCCI: Cool.
MARK DOUGLAS: No,
not Neil Peart.
Geddy Lee-ing out.
LOUIS TUCCI: Oh, yeah.
He's Canadian, by the way.
STEVE ROSEN: So is Louis.
MARK DOUGLAS: You must be, too.
LOUIS TUCCI: I am, too.
MARK DOUGLAS: Canadian pride.
Let's see, what else?
Anybody else have any questions?
No?
OK.
So I feel--
I kind of came
into this blindly.
Sometimes I don't
like to know anything.
And I totally thought
that it was all true.
I thought, well,
that's Josh Cohen,
and these are his
actor friends who
are helping him tell the story.
But let me tell you why.
Because I've lived in New York
since 1996, which makes me old,
but a version of just about
everything that happened
happened to me.
Like, I was a bellman.
And I'm not going to make
this about me for too long.
But I was a bellman, and
once some woman checked in
and she went up to her
room and was waiting for me
to bring up her bags.
I looked out and on the
curb, there was an envelope,
and I went out and looked at
it, and it was all hundreds.
And I just kind of flipped
through and I was like--
and I looked around, and it was
one of those rare moments where
nobody was seeing me.
And I was like, what to do?
And so I was like, I don't know.
And the woman was
kind of bitchy.
So this ties in with
his whole moral dilemma.
I'm not just--
DAVID ROSSMER: This is
actually not a performance.
We actually are
here to arrest you.
Here he is, folks.
STEVE ROSEN: He admitted
to it, everyone.
DAVID ROSSMER: Take him away.
MARK DOUGLAS: I
wrestled with it.
DAVID ROSSMER: Finally.
MARK DOUGLAS: I
wrestled with it.
Didn't even count it because I
was afraid of how much it was.
And I was like, I can't--
I am at work.
So I went up and I said, hey,
did you by any chance drop
an envelope?
And she looked in her
purse and was like,
I saw the look of panic and
I just went here you go.
I found it on the street.
And she-- she literally
went thanks, and handed me
the dollar she was
already going to tip me.
I thought at least she'd peel
off one of those hundreds.
So that's what happens
in real life, bub.
But a lot of it is about
the non-appreciation
of the other Josh Cohen.
But anyway, I thought--
I thought it was real.
How much was it taken from
real life, not to quote
the song, but--
DAVID ROSSMER: We
always-- no, it's OK.
We always say that the show is
under the umbrella of truth.
When we started writing it, we
were actually in Los Angeles,
and we had a TV
meeting the next day.
We were very nervous.
And Steve suggested
playing a video game
in the sublet apartment he had.
And they had-- I think
it was Mario Kart.
And we never ended
up playing the game
because the opening screen--
the music sounded like a
long lost Neil Diamond album.
And so we grabbed the
guitar off the sublet wall,
and by the end of the night, we
had written five or six songs
to lyrics of takeout menus.
I think "Samuel Cohen's
Family Tree" was like--
STEVE ROSEN: It was like
"Angel's Korean Barbecue."
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah.
And--
STEVE ROSEN: (SINGING)
Angel's Korean barbecue.
DAVID ROSSMER:
(SINGING) barbecue.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, I want
to see that musical.
DAVID ROSSMER: That's--
[INAUDIBLE] mean something.
STEVE ROSEN: Very
different musical.
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah.
But we just were
having so much fun.
And we started to write all
these fake Neil Diamond songs.
Like, what would be on a
long lost Neil Diamond album?
And by the time we
were done, we were
more interested in this idea
than we were in the TV thing.
And we said, what
musical would justify
having the entire score
feel like an album inspired
by Neil Diamond?
And we thought, well,
Steve, you were once robbed.
What if this
character was robbed
of everything but this CD?
And so that's all
he had to listen to,
so his whole world becomes
sort of Neil Diamond.
And then I brought
up a story that
happened to me that was true.
And we said, oh, that
would really connect well.
And then we started to put
together all these true stories
from our lives that
made each other laugh.
So the show is comprised
of a bunch of stories
that are true from our lives.
And it's fun to sort of
relive them every night,
and horrifying, too.
But it's-- and that was
really where we started.
We knew we always
wanted-- we always
talked about sort of telling a
Job-like story of someone who
gets something they
think they want
and by losing it ends up
finding what they really wanted,
which in this case is love.
But speaking to your point about
feeling like this is universal
and that this has
happened, right
when we first did the show--
we met at summer
camp, you know, where
all Jews do in the summer.
And-- and this guy who
went to camp with us named
Josh Cohen had left a message.
And he said, please
call me back.
It's very urgent.
And I called him back.
And he said, I just
wanted to talk to you
because I'm very upset that you
would write a musical about me
and not tell me.
And I said, Josh, we both
knew you as an acquaintance.
We liked you.
We were friends, but we
don't know a ton about you.
We would never write a
show without asking you
for permission.
And he said, oh, oh, that's
interesting because I'm broke,
I'm alone, and I
like Neil Diamond.
MARK DOUGLAS: He's got
the flannel shirt on.
Like, come on, buddy.
DAVID ROSSMER: Totally.
And so we thought, this--
we may have a show here
that speaks to more
people than just us.
And we had written it to
kind of cheer ourselves up.
We were single at the time.
And we've always said since
then, if you come see the show,
it's sort of like
a good luck charm
because it has birthed couples.
And the stage manager and
the associate stage manager
of one production are
now married with a kid.
And people, whether it's
love or just having bad luck
in their lives, when
they come see the show,
something happens
and they always
write to us afterwards and say
that their lives have somehow
changed.
And so we're kind of like this
weird somatic rabbit's foot.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, it did-- it
did have a great sort of theme
of just putting-- if you
put yourself out there,
no matter the
weirdest possible way,
just writing angry letters
to the other Josh Cohen
and then someone finds
those and likes those,
and then that happens to be
the woman that-- not you, Mary,
which I thought it was.
I totally bought it.
But yeah, I love
that idea that--
I felt like it really
captured New York
in a way that didn't overdo it.
I think that first line about--
I'm going to butcher it--
about burglary being a rite
of passage in New York.
Like, I remember
when I got mugged,
and I wanted so much
sympathy from everyone,
and I happened to
speak to people
who had lived in the
city their whole lives
and they were like,
yeah, I've been mugged.
And I was like, yeah,
but did you get hit?
I got hit.
And they were like,
not the first time.
And then you're just like,
that's what New York--
it's just brutal,
brutal, brutal.
And then out of nowhere,
it turns out OK.
That's and that's why
I really thought, yeah,
this all happened.
I totally bought it.
And I wish you weren't
a liar is basically--
STEVE ROSEN: It's
so nice to hear
but I think that
what it speaks to
is sort of the universal
experience of getting crapped
on.
And I think that that's
something that we all
can sort of relate to.
And to speak to David's
point, his story about camp,
NPR did a piece this weekend.
There was another Josh Cohen
at that camp who also thought
the musical was about him.
So people wind up
leaving this story--
MARK DOUGLAS: Josh Cohens
are inherently narcissistic.
I don't know if you know that.
They tend to think
everything is about them.
They tend to think they're the
first one to wear the shirt.
STEVE ROSEN: Totally, totally.
MARK DOUGLAS: But--
DAVID ROSSMER: It doesn't
help that Josh Cohen is
literally like the John
Smith of Jewish names, too.
MARK DOUGLAS: Right, right.
Exactly.
So you-- you had to learn the
most instruments, did you not?
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE:
Yes, I think
that is probably accurate.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, how
many-- how many instruments
did you have to
start from scratch?
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE: Well,
I had played piano, and so 5
of the 11 instruments I
play are piano related.
We have piano, accordion,
keytar, glockenspiel,
and melodica.
CATHRYN WAKE: That's
a keytar, everyone.
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE:
That's correct.
CATHRYN WAKE: Keytar.
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE:
We're back to the '80s.
You're welcome.
So those were all
familiar enough,
but then I also learned acoustic
guitar, and electric bass,
and violin, and clarinet, and
I do some auxiliary percussion.
And at earlier
versions of the show
as we were talking about
with the preview process,
we also had saxophone,
oboe, and trumpet
in there, which were cut between
previews and opening night.
MARK DOUGLAS: So you
learned those for nothing.
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE: So I
But you know what?
Now I can do--
I can teach my Intro
to the Symphony class.
You know?
I've got a little bit of every
instrument in my bones now.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
So has there ever
been any mishaps
where I'm supposed
to have a bass
but I have a ukulele
someone handed me?
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE:
Well, we've
had moments where
something is going wrong,
a guitar doesn't get on fast
enough, and so I'm like,
oh, I'm holding a
baritone ukulele.
What chord is that that
he's about to play but he
doesn't have the answer--
OK, cool.
I'll play that on
this instrument.
So we do a lot of in the moment
fixing, saving, tweaking.
If a bass goes out,
we have a bass sound
we can use on the keytar.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, wow.
ELIZABETH NESTLERODE: So we try
to think of as many contingency
plans as possible as well as
having backup instruments.
Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: Louis,
that opening bass line,
what's that from?
Is that influenced by something?
I feel like--
LOUIS TUCCI: Well,
David and Dan--
MARK DOUGLAS: I just
wanted to ask you
because I haven't spoken
to you in a while.
LOUIS TUCCI: --and
Steve wrote that.
I mean, it's a fun bass part.
It's a very fun bass part.
MARK DOUGLAS: You play
the hell out of it.
LOUIS TUCCI: Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
It's not really
easy, but it's fun
to play once you
get it in your body.
MARK DOUGLAS: But you were
talking about Mario Kart.
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: That--
that bass line felt
very video game inspired to me.
Is that-- is that something
I'm making up or--
DAVID ROSSMER: No, no.
It was probably
inspired by that game.
Funny enough, it was--
I think the song
that was our lead
in for that particular
bass was a Billy Joel
song, strangely enough.
He has one--
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, yeah.
DAVID ROSSMER: --country-esque
song called "Traveling Prayer"
that, like, Dolly Parton
covered or something.
And that opening number
you're talking about actually
was the last song we
ever wrote for the show.
We always knew that the show
needed an opening number
and we weren't quite
sure what it was.
It was a really
tough nut to crack.
Like, how do you
introduce this character
and let the audience
know that he's
going to be OK without
telling them how?
And so that was--
STEVE ROSEN: And that
they're the same person
at the same time, too.
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah, that
they're the same person.
And so we had gone through
a bunch of versions.
And that was, for some
reason, this is weird,
obscure Billy Joel
song spoke to us.
And so that was really where
that bass line came from.
Don't tell Billy.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
know, I actually--
I felt like I heard a little
bit-- there's one song,
I can't remember which one now,
that almost has "it's my life"
little doo dee, doo dee.
DAVID ROSSMER: That's right,
the beginning of "Neil Life."
It is my life.
MARK DOUGLAS: See, the other
thing about thinking it
was a true story, I'm
like, what if they found
a Hootie and the Blowfish CD?
Would all the songs have to--
(SINGING) real life.
So did you have to
audition as Neil Young?
Did you have to--
I mean, Neil Young.
JANE BRUCE: That's so funny.
MARK DOUGLAS: That
would have been--
Neil Young.
DAVID ROSSMER: We
actually made people--
yeah, we threw a
curveball at them.
That's funny because I-- they
said bring in an instrument
if you do, and I play guitar.
And I cover a Neil Young song,
so for my initial audition
where I had to play a not--
they were like, now sing
something of your own.
I was like, I'll
do the other Neil.
But yes, I did.
I watched some videos and
I had some hip thrusts.
I think one of our producers
said, you did your research.
Because I had it
in my hips already.
MARK DOUGLAS: I feel like
it might be difficult to,
like-- you want to
take care of your voice
while trying to do a
Neil Diamond voice.
It's a lot of (VOCAL FRY).
JANE BRUCE: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
know, I feel like you
could get a little graveled
out and maybe blow it out.
Does that ever happen?
Does anybody ever hurt
themselves doing it?
JANE BRUCE: Well, I'm only two
and a half weeks in to my run,
but yeah, it's something that
I'm still definitely figuring
out.
DAVID ROSSMER: How
does Neil do it?
That's my question.
JANE BRUCE: I know, yeah.
DAVID ROSSMER: And Tom Waits.
MARK DOUGLAS: I don't know.
Yeah, and I'm thinking, what
if he found a Tom Waits CD?
Would everything have
to-- (VOCAL FRY).
Let's see.
What else?
Any questions from the audience?
Oh, yes.
We have one.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
thank you for coming.
So I bought my
tickets for the show.
It's in a few weeks.
And it was because
specifically I
think one of the reviews
compared it to Seinfeld meets
Rodgers and Hammerstein.
But obviously,
that's a reviewer.
I was wondering if
you had any actual
either comedic or
musical influences
that sort of drove you
to where you are today,
or if anyone in
the cast recognizes
any comedic or
musical influences.
Thank you.
DAVID ROSSMER: That's
a great question.
STEVE ROSEN: That's
Yeah, we have a lot of--
David and I have a lot
of comedic influences.
Since we've known each
other since we were kids,
we make each other laugh a lot.
And we watch a lot
of the same stuff.
We love some of the same
old crazy movies like--
there's that Neil Simon
movie "Murder By Death"
which makes us laugh a
lot, a lot of Seinfeld,
that type of humor.
I think also just culturally,
growing up in a Jewish family--
we both grew up in a similarly
styled Jewish family,
so our senses of
humor were shaped
by a lot of the same stuff.
DAVID ROSSMER: And there's
a lot of pop culture
references in the show of things
we love and were influenced by.
There's a ton of Willy Wonka
references, which is probably
fun for anyone who knows
it and other people
are like, what are
they talking about?
MARK DOUGLAS: No,
those were great.
DAVID ROSSMER: Because we
literally do scenes from--
the show sort of
morphs into scenes
from Willy Wonka, Star Wars,
what are some of the others?
STEVE ROSEN: Yeah, we have
Neil Diamond in there,
we have that song,
(SINGING) nobody
going to break up my style.
DAVID ROSSMER: Yes.
STEVE ROSEN: Yeah,
there are a lot
of references in "The
Other Josh Cohen"
that come up in
our everyday life.
But yeah, we love popular
culture like anyone else
and so it feels-- the show
feels very current because it's
based on the stuff that we see
and love and watch every day.
DAVID ROSSMER: And
because of that,
it's kind of a
musical for people
who love musicals, but also
for people who don't normally.
Like, I love when people are
like, oh, I don't want to come.
I hate musicals.
I was like, have we
got a show for you.
Because star-- Darth Vader
comes out of a refrigerator.
That doesn't happen in--
MARK DOUGLAS: Come on.
Yeah.
DAVID ROSSMER:
--"Phantom of the Opera."
I mean, it should.
STEVE ROSEN: Yet.
MARK DOUGLAS: Unless you're
on hallucinogenics, no.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I saw the show, loved it.
And it's one of my
favorites I've ever seen.
And I've seen a lot of shows.
DAVID ROSSMER: Thank you.
STEVE ROSEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I'm in
big theater nerd,
so I have a little bit more
of a specific question.
I've listened to the
album a bunch of times.
How did you get them all?
How did you get them?
MARK DOUGLAS: That was on
my list, good question.
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah, so she's
referring to the CD we made.
And we don't have the cast on
because we made it before we
ever even cast the show.
We knew we wanted to have an
album ready to go to, you know,
have for the lobby, and
for people to sort of get
a sense of the music.
So Steve and I had co-created
with Dan Lipton and Sarah
Salzberg this show called
"Don't quit your night job."
and we had done
it for many years
and we had raised a ton of money
for charity called Open Doors
that Wendy Wasserstein, a
wonderful playwright, started.
And it was an improv show.
And we would do crazy stuff.
We would do, like,
musical mad libs.
We would have Sting come.
And no one would
know he was there
and we'd come out and get a
mad lib, adjectives, and verbs,
and nouns, and no one would know
what the song was going to be.
And out would come Sting singing
"Every Breath You Take" to,
like--
MARK DOUGLAS: Actual Sting?
DAVID ROSSMER: Actual--
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, wow.
DAVID ROSSMER: The actual Sting.
Huey Lewis, we had every
Broadway star, Kelli O'Hara,
and all these people would come
and do these ridiculous skits.
It was like Saturday Night
Live for theater, in a way.
And we had made a lot
of friends that way.
And so we have everyone on
this album from Kelli O'Hara,
to Chita Rivera, to Sutton
Foster, to Brian D'Arcy James,
to James Roday, to Hank Azaria.
Thank you.
Jimmy Simpson, James Monroe
Iglehart, Lindsay Mendez,
all of these insane people.
Because the theater community,
like working on this show,
there is a strong sense
of community and support.
And so all these people had
seen the show over the years
or had heard about
it, and when we
said we have a chance to
participate in this, and Chita
Rivera's like, well, I
don't play the drums,
but maybe I can
sing on the album.
And so we got a chance
to use them that way.
MARK DOUGLAS: Didn't you say
Brian D'Arcy James nailed it
in one take?
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah, One
Take James, we called him.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: Anyway,
you've won a lot of awards,
but I think the most prestigious
honor is that you guys made it
to page 6 because of a
bundt, a stolen bundt cake.
I mean, talk about Seinfeld.
That is like-- somebody
stole the bundt cake.
I mean, it's just--
talk to me about the bundt cake.
STEVE ROSEN: Well, the show--
so when you come in to see
the show, if you see the show,
as you're coming into the
theater, you're coming in
and the set is a fully
furnished apartment.
And during the half an hour
before the show begins,
you are inadvertently
watching a burglar steal
every single thing out of
the apartment so by the time
the show starts
it's totally empty.
And the last thing that
he steals is a bundt cake.
And our theater, like an office,
has a community refrigerator
where we kept the bundt cake.
And someone in--
someone somewhere
thought that that was an open
call bundt cake for anyone
who wanted bundt cake.
And so one night we had to
run out and grab more bundt
cake because there
was no bundt cake.
DAVID ROSSMER: I think,
like, three times
they went for the bundt
cake, and they were like--
you would just see
someone running
across the street to Little Pie
Company to get the bundt cake.
MARK DOUGLAS: Serves him
right, though, the thief.
Yeah, well, I knew I
was going to like it
right away because when
I came in I don't think
I saw the entirety
of the burgling.
But I noticed that Kenny
Loggins was playing.
"Heart to Heart," and then it
kind of went from one yacht
rock song to the next.
And I was like, I--
I made this playlist.
STEVE ROSEN: You
and Bart Fasbender.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's
very white, but--
but was that supposed
to be Josh's music?
Did I miss a part where
the burglar was like--
did he put that on?
Or was that just house music?
STEVE ROSEN: I think--
I think the idea was there
some-- a very traumatic event--
our sound designer,
Bart Fasbender,
is a wonderful genius.
It's such a challenge to
make the sound of a rock
band come alive in a show.
But the idea that
something so traumatic
was happening to this person
that we haven't met yet
to such innocuous music like
Kenny Loggins and Chicago.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, it
was supposed to be lame.
I get it.
DAVID ROSSMER: No, no, no.
It's good.
STEVE ROSEN: And we
want it every night.
Every night is different.
We knew you were there.
We go to everyone's
playlists and we find out
what they're listening to.
We want to make it
your experience.
MARK DOUGLAS: OK, good.
Good.
That's nice.
I wouldn't be surprised.
I was talking about
something other day
and then it got suggested
to me in an add.
Somebody in this building is
responsible for it, I'm sure.
They're listening.
DAVID ROSSMER:
Speak into my lapel.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, yeah.
I love the song "One CD,"
which I thought at first--
because they leave you with
only one CD, and I thought,
I wonder if there's,
like, a temptation
to update the technology
as time goes by.
And then I thought--
then I realized as
it went through,
the more obsolete CDs get, the
sadder and funnier that gets.
So it's kind of nice and it
sort of put it in a time.
Was it supposed
to be, like, '90s,
or was it just that,
no, it's like yesterday,
and this guy still
has a discman.
STEVE ROSEN: Well, he has to
go out and buy the discman.
I think it takes place today.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, right, right.
STEVE ROSEN: I think
it sort of is--
we're put in this
situation where
we live in this digital
age where all of a sudden
this guy's robbed of everything
and is sort of forced,
like Job, to go back
into an analog existence.
MARK DOUGLAS: Right.
STEVE ROSEN: And so that's
what he has to listen to.
And then when his phone
dies, he has to figure out
how to use a landline phone.
It's like the guy is-- he is--
MARK DOUGLAS: The greatest
landline phone ever.
It's a Darth Vader head
that you speak into.
DAVID ROSSMER: It actually
moves and breathes.
STEVE ROSEN: It did
until we broke it.
DAVID ROSSMER: Yeah,
But yeah, he actually-- at
one point he calls 4-1-1.
There's a lot of little secret
things along the way, Easter
eggs and things like
that, because he's
the underdog in the story.
What no one would
probably notice
is that everything in the
story that he has is always
the underdog product.
Like, he likes Turkey
Hill ice cream,
and he's a member of HSBC Bank.
MARK DOUGLAS: I did notice that.
I was like, he just said he's--
DAVID ROSSMER: He
likes the Mets.
MARK DOUGLAS: He
finished a turkey--
yeah.
He finished a Turkey Hill
vanilla pint of ice cream.
DAVID ROSSMER: French vanilla.
MARK DOUGLAS: I was
like, wow, that's a--
DAVID ROSSMER: Not
your go-to, yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: Really
living it up, huh?
No chocolate in there, nothing?
Just--
STEVE ROSEN: It's French.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, I think--
I think we're about up.
Anybody else want to ask--
anybody else have any burning
questions?
No?
Well, I just want to
thank you guys again
for bringing your talents
to us on Valentine's Day.
And I just love the show.
You guys are incredible.
Please see it.
You will not regret it.
And let's give another
warm, warm round of applause
for The Other Josh Cohen cast.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID ROSSMER: Thank you.
STEVE ROSEN: Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
DAVID ROSSMER: Thank you.
This place is amazing.
Thank you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]